so while times are scary the number one
thing you can do is to make sure you
improve so you get better strategies
I've been consuming a lot of content
lately more books this year than I did
the year before and the year prior to
that there's five books I want to
recommend you to read number one is how
to my default by Jim Collins it's not a
new book but you must read it because it
talks about the five stages companies go
through and societies go through when
they fall number two is a book called
after Steve it's about after Steve Jobs
it's a newer book that just came out the
stories you will learn about Tim Cook
how he dealt with President Trump versus
Obama versus how he got his job how he
was recruited what happened to the
company what his strengths are what jobs
did I've not heard this I've heard a lot
of stories I've consumed a lot of
content on Apple and Steve Jobs you will
not be able to poke put this book down
number three is how to invest by David
Rubinstein four billion auto man founder
of Carlisle group he's got one of the
best personalities he's a great
interviewer of these people and he goes
and sits down with Larry Fink he sits
down with Ray dalio he sits down with
everybody that build a great great hedge
fund Financial firm and you'll learn
about their investment philosophies of
how these Behemoth investors hedge fund
money managers became who they became
it's it's a perfect time to get clear on
your investment philosophy number four
number four is going to be Atlas Shrug
if you've never read it and you've never
gone through it and you don't have a
personal relationship with John Galt
this is the season to go read the book
download the audio just take a break at
night in the morning when you wake up go
finish Atlas Shrug you'll sit there and
you can thank me later when you read
this book on how powerful of a book it
is so book number four is Atlas Shrug
and last but not least one of the
craziest stories a billionaire who
married John F Kennedy's wife after she
was widowed and the arrangement of his
marriage to Jackie which was forever you
were married he passed to pay roughly 10
million just a wild story of how this
person made his money Onassis I think
it's called the extra extravagant life
of Onassis if you've never read it the
audiobook is fantastic highly recommend
you make that as one of the five books
to read during this season and by the
way if you're an entrepreneur you've
never seen my top 52 books to read as an
entrepreneur in a year and you want to
take up that challenge click on the link
over here you'll get an email or PDF to
find that the top 52 books to read as an
entrepreneur take care everybody bye
[Applause]
[Music]